it started with a piano a white piano
that I had in my living room in the keys
and I would play the piano and I knew
chords at that time too I would play the
piano and I would feel like my soul was
crying it was crying music I swear it's
like this like not really like a cold
rush but like something was happening
with My Soul as I played and struck
different chords and ever since then I
wanted to make music I love making music
it's definitely my happy place Aaron
Carter has died he was 34 years old the
singer was found dead on Saturday at his
home just outside of Los Angeles a cause
of death is not yet confirmed but he
reportedly drowned in his bathtub
[Music]
Aaron shot to Fame in the late 90s
launching his own successful music
career after his brother Nick found Fame
with the Backstreet Boys oh yeah I mean
I've been performing a lot I mean for my
age I've been performing since I was
like six years old I was in a group
called Dead End like when I was when I
was six years old and it was nothing it
was nothing really big we just did like
coffee houses and things but you know
that's you know I think that's how I got
started kind of but then I uh I met so
stage fright is not an issue for you no
of course not no I mean uh like I said
I've been the first time I ever
performed I was like I thought I was
gonna pee my pants I mean it was just
really scary for me there's only like
200 people but it was really scary as he
entered adulthood tabloid trouble
followed and he was open about his
struggles with his family mental health
and substance abuse what I need is
people to
understand that I'm human
and I make mistakes just like every
other human in this world
ET was last with the star in 2019
alongside his mother Jane you know the
hopes of the future are this don't come
at me the wrong way because I I will I
will fight to protect my rights and what
our four brothers stood for what air uh
that being said Aaron loves his family
very much and that's where his heart is
at and that's where he's coming from
he's coming from Love and he's just
wanting to see it return
[Music]
foreign
[Music]